david do you think that the lunatic
trumpist elected officials that one in
2020
like marjorie taylor greene lauren
beaubert
madison cawthorne and others will be
re-elected in 2022.
this is a cut this is like a chicken egg
question we wonder will trump really run
in 2024
we wonder is the republican party going
in the direction of trump
or are they going to reject trump going
forward
that and this question of do marjorie
taylor green madison cawthorne and
lauren bobert become
one-term anomalies or anomalies
depending on your preference both
pronunciations valid
or do they get re-elected and ingrain
these
sort of vapid trumpian candidates with
no policy ideas
into congress the tea party in 2010
you'll remember essentially disappeared
as a standalone group it's now a caucus
within the house of representatives
and many tea party ideas sort of became
integrated into the republican party
but not as cartoonishly as they
presented themselves in 2010.
something similar could happen with
trumpism where some of these folks
moderate and remain in the party or they
all get crushed in 2022 and that signals
a broader
rejection of trumpism going forward i
think the reason that at his speech at
cpac a week or two ago
two weeks ago wait three two weeks you
know recently
uh i don't even know i don't even know
what year it is never mind when trump
spoke no in the last month trump spoke
at cpac
one of the reasons strategically that it
made sense for trump not to announce a
2024
run but to announce that he now is going
to be helping candidates in 2022
to donate to his pack so on and so forth
is that gauging his level of influence
through the elections of those he
supports in 2022 will serve as a good
signal
as to whether he should run in 2024
whether he has a shot
in 2024. so i think the answer is it
remains to be seen
trump's influence will determine whether
hawthorne beau bird and green
get re-elected green cawthorn and bobert
getting re-elected or not will signal
the strength of trumpism
going into 2024 which will likely inform
whether or not donald trump runs i still
lean to trump doesn't run
my my thought is that to some degree
trumpism will fade over the next two to
three years
trump will be nearly 80. and i see him
just kind of moving on to something else
or for other reasons uh you know
health becomes more of a question mark
and uh
trump is not a particularly healthy guy
my overall prediction is if i had to bet
today i bet if you give me even odds and
i'm not a betting man but if you gave me
even odds
i bet trump doesn't run in 2024. let me
know your thoughts
we've got a great bonus show for you
today get instant access to the bonus
show
by signing up right now at
joinpakman.com
today's episode is sponsored by bluechu
a unique
online service delivering the same
active ingredients as viagra and cialis
in a chewable form and at a fraction of
the cost
and they're giving my audience an entire
month's supply for
free take a short quiz on the bluechew
website
a licensed doctor approves your
prescription and the medication goes
right to your home in a discreet package
no driving to the doctor's office
having a possibly awkward conversation
waiting in line at the pharmacy
bluechu replaces the entire process with
a few
clicks and way less expensive and all of
bluetooth tablets are made
in the united states so if you think you
could benefit from an
extra boost of confidence go to
bluechew.com the link is under this
video and they'll give you an entire
month's supply for
free when you use promo code pacman just
pay five dollars for shipping